speaking of banana bread we've got a
name game I haven't done this in a while
sending more of these these are fun
just another mustache Austin Cortina are
hot so guys I live in LA and all bets
have been off during kovat as far as
diet goes a little name game for you
desserts gang gang buzz buzz peace out
mmm that means guys the limit here what
are the rules of this game again any
dessert there you go not for dinner
you can't say fruit by the foot kids
named candy yeah those are desserts
let's be legit desserts okay yep
carrot cake that's a what I was gonna
say man it's a vegetable cake you know
it's you know it's it's healthy Anna's
cake um I will go with bread pudding
lemon meringue pie another nice one yep
creme brulee I'm gonna say coconut cream
pie blueberry there's not a lot of
blueberry on the menu blue great there's
a apple pie you know everybody got that
Apple hit are you putting in that book
you bringing that beat as fire right
here when everybody's happy a good apple
pie Omaha you start living bro you
taught more desserts wrong what if you
come around here with that dude the not
tiramisu you later
and don't make me hit you with that
peach cobbler what I really like is that
up with some tiramisu Trevor how about
that nice just I like a nice plain
vanilla scoop Sandra Bullock with that
movie with her Eisenberg box yeah you
look like you're gay light on the birds
dude churros it's so many beauty mmm is
serve ice-cream layups
dude fried I thought I knew regular ice
cream melted ice cream ice cream pies
we're eating sandwiches with Midwest
thing ever has a here's a handful of
whipped cream a little yard whipped
cream if you trying to help you get some
nice [ __ ] berries a little whipped
cream on top oh yeah two brothers
dude I can't Lisa tiramisu tell me no I
don't want with chocolate cake yeah
anyone has that chocolate cake oh you
could have a triple chocolate cake
double chocolate devil's chocolate
chairman chocolate German chocolate
cheese came down then the cheese carrot
that pound cake Mexican chocolate
vanilla do I love ya tres leches dog
three milks but get that milk shake
hitter oh you know Chili's get a full
rack of ribs and wash it down with a
shot
shape and they have molten lava cake
there too damn yes huh Sakura bananas
and you bailed out Mizuki oh man yeah
you could dog mmm
how'd you what happened how do you say
to your me so know what cuz when your
name and I'm thinking so I didn't hear
you really say tara misu
I heard your other one I think said
tapioca pudding oh yeah can what with
bread pudding chocolate pudding vanilla
pudding those limo cheese oh yeah
Chinese dessert it's Japanese but that's
a nice try it is yeah oh wow close
enough it's good I did it in China dude
that's how much I like it I really would
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]